Where are we going i don't know your house
oh my god okay i think you said you're
not really like me yeah well not anymore
hello peter do i know you we started getting
some visitors from this is every my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get through this
and we're gonna get through it together
Welcome back everyone this is my new spider-man
no way home video for the sinister six changes
there's a bunch of costume upgrades and a bunch
of new scenes to break down so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing a giveaway for imax
tickets for the movie all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
moment from the trailers in the comments i believe
they're also dropping a new trailer on monday when
they start releasing tickets officially to
everyone so whenever they do release that of
course i'll do a new video for it but i'll just
talk about the new footage here then i'll talk
about the sinister six changes the big costume
upgrades and what's actually going on with their
plan in the movie because obviously they don't
want to go back to being dead if doctor strange
sends them back to their original universes and
it all has something to do with what's happening
here with the tears in reality around the statue
of liberty with this giant captain america shield
in doctor strange's special magic box
that spider-man is trying to trap them in
but there's this brand new scene where spider-man
and mj are actually talking about her father and
the funny thing is we've never actually met him
in the spider-man movies the mcu spider-man movies
i believe there was some deleted scenes either it
was in spider-man far from home or maybe it was
spider-man homecoming where they were going to get
a little more into her home life and just show you
how she was basically living on the poverty
line they were kind of doing a version of
the mary jane origin story if you remember
the tobey maguire kirsten dunst mary jane
the difference with zendaya's version of the
character though is that her name is michelle
jones and that's what mj stands for but they're
clearly riffing on mary jane from the comics and
the tobey maguire spider-man movies it's just
that they rebooted the spider-man franchise and
redid the origin story so many times that
when they rebooted with tom holland in the
mcu they didn't want to just go back to doing
the exact same characters in the exact same
way but they still wanted to do versions
of all those classic comic book characters
so that's why a lot of the tom holland mcu
spider-man characters and his friends are
all remixes of versions of the characters that
you've seen from the comics in the other movies
probably the biggest differences with this version
of the mj character is that she's really studious
like she's super smart very counter culture
mistrustful of authority the government like she
was the one who suggested to peter and ned leeds
that they prepped their gear for their europe
trip and spider-man far from home so that the
government couldn't track them using their phones
by the way travel tip you should probably download
a vpn on your phone just so that the government
can't track you while we're abroad and that was
before she found out that peter was spider-man
you also learned that she's really observant
in a way that they didn't really get into
with the kirsten dunst mary jane like she had
suspected something was going on with peter they
kind of teased that out through all the different
spider-man movies to spider-man far from home the
big joke being that she didn't actually fully put
two and two together like she hadn't connected all
the dots and she was like wait what i was just
bluffing i knew that something was going on but
i didn't know that you were spider-man so the
dynamics between them are fairly similar but so
much about her character just feels very different
there's a whole different vibe about her but one
of the biggest easter eggs that you spotted in
here is the classic gwen stacy death scene with
her falling from the statue of liberty which is
something that happened with spider-man before
he actually got into a relationship with mary
jane if you haven't read a lot of the classic
spider-man comics gwen stacy came before mary jane
she was killed when she was thrown off a building
spider-man wasn't able to save her it wasn't till
later that he started going out with mary jane and
they became a couple they kind of did a version of
that with the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
movies like they started with gwen stacy when he
was in high school then followed them did the big
death scene and had they continued with amazing
spider-man 3 they would have eventually set up
with the mary jane's story arc there was even a
version of mary jane played by shailene woodley
that they filmed scenes for in amazing spider-man
2 but i guess they just decided to delete them
because it was just too much they were piling too
many characters into the movie already but i think
we can all assume that they're not going to kill
off mj like this whole scene here with the gwen
stacy death scene is a big misdirect early theory
is that andrew garfield's amazing spider-man is
going to wind up saving her in kind of redeeming
himself for not being able to save his gwen stacy
and if it wasn't clear they are gonna bring back
the tom hand mcu spider-man in new spider-man
movies like a new trilogy that'll be a completely
different storyline and i think part of the idea
is that they would also bring back zendaya's
mj character is part of that arc too it's a bit
more of a question as to what's going on with all
the side characters these supporting characters
there is supposed to be a subplot in the movie
about peter trying to get accepted to mit because
he's already a science whiz but iron man went to
mit and since he's like his surrogate father in
the mcu papa bless he's also trying to get into
the same school the funny thing though is that
because iron man is like a super genius in the mcu
by the time peter had become spider-man iron man
was getting ready to graduate from mit like
he was a teenager when he graduated from mit
but regardless of what happens with that plot
with the mit subplot of him trying to get into
college during the film he will eventually go
to college in that next spider-man trilogy it
just might not wind up being mit side note 2
if you guys have seen any of my black panther
2 videos i did a first look video because they
released some footage of them filming at mit
i believe it was shuri and okoye coming to mit to
peep on riri williams because of the whole armor
suit subplot from the comics with her character so
spider-man may or may not wind up going to college
with riri williams at mit in the mcu as for all
the big sinister six changes in their storyline
during the movie if you've seen the new poster
you can actually get a much better look at what
their upgraded mcu costumes look like i call them
upgrades but really it's just different versions
of the costumes that are made to be more comic
book accurate starting with willem dafoe's green
goblin like i said a couple weeks ago i did a
big first look for his costume that we got behind
the scenes of he's got this battle damaged and
repaired version of his green goblin suit from
that first tobey maguire spider-man movie and his
glider they made it look a little bit shinier at
first before it gets damaged but it's meant to be
the exact same suit it looks like he's wearing the
helmet at the beginning of his arc in the movie
like during this big bridge fight scene with the
pumpkin bombs but then later during this night
scene of what seems like the big final boss fight
the statue of liberty he's on his glider he's
not wearing the mask he's just wearing goggles
chucking a bunch of pumpkin bombs and he's wearing
a very comic book accurate strap and pouch to hold
all his gear and it's the same situation with
electro like they're slowly making him more comic
book accurate with all these mcu costume changes
he's wearing a harness here that's hooked up to an
iron man arc reactor if you can't see the symbol
it's the arc reactor from the end of iron man 2 in
the first avengers movie that he built using that
new infinity stone element electro is using the
arc reactor to keep himself at full charge during
all of his fights because when he uses his powers
he loses charge he gets weaker and weaker and
weaker so an arc reactor would solve that problem
notice the electricity halo around his head it's
forming that star shape from the comics from his
classic costume the harness itself also kind of
resembles the lines of the classic costume too
sandman is probably one of the few characters
that hasn't really changed though this mcu glow
up because they already had a pretty comic
book accurate version in spider-man 3. it's
pretty easy to do him comic book accurate but
it does look like they tuned the lizard up quite
a bit with modern special effects now his basic
transformation like the science behind it hasn't
changed it's the same version of the lizard he
just looks way better because they're using better
graphics the big theory right now is that the
sinister six characters who actually do team up in
the movie green goblin electro sandman and lizard
like during this big statue of liberty fight scene
it seems like green goblin is the one leading the
team like he's meant to be the actual main villain
and he's the one who comes up with their plan to
manipulate doctor strange's box or his spell or
use some technology that they rig up to stop him
from sending them back to their original universes
like stopping doctor strange from fixing
the tears in reality and undoing the spell
because if they get sent back they'll just go
back to being dead and none of them want that
and that's probably why doctor strange is telling
spider-man in this scene here that you have to
capture them before they break all of reality
like what the green goblin and the sinister six
are doing threatens to destroy all of reality like
what they do will only make things worse until the
fabric of all reality tear so badly the multiverse
just collapses on itself which might sound
familiar because that sounds a lot like what he
who remains version of king was talking about
during the loki series with the kang multiverse
war each variant fighting to preserve their
universe and annihilate the others this is
almost the end of everything and everyone
the difference is that all the kang variants
were just erasing going around destroying
other realities one at a time trying to make their
own timelines the dominant one but it was still a
mutually assured destruction situation where
the war threatened to destroy every universe
every timeline so different methods but same
result goodbye all of reality i'm not sure if
they're gonna be any big kang easter eggs during
spider-man no way home because we're not really
supposed to see the actual version of kang the
conqueror like the real main villain till ant-man
3 quantumania or loki season 2 depending on which
of those drops first but i think we can already
assume that doctor strange and spider-man are at
least partially successful because the mcu has to
survive long enough through the end of the movie
into the beginning of doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness but early theory they'll probably just
end things without completely fixing everything
like the fabric of reality will still be very
weak as if doctor strange were to fix these
tears with a bunch of magical duct tape like
don't push too hard on this or blow too hard
because they'll break again suddenly off in the
distance you can see scarlet witch saying hold
my dark hole that she just rips through to other
universes again gotta find my kids but post all
your theories in the comments below what do you
think green goblin in these other sinister six
characters actual plan is that threatens all of
reality like i said there's supposed to be some
special new preview some new footage that'll drop
on monday when they actually put tickets on sale
and i'll just keep doing my imax ticket giveaway
in all my spider-man videos sony just released a
brand new venom let the be carnage deleted scene
all about no god of the symbiotes you can click
here for my video about that and you can click
here for my full hawkeye episode 1 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!